Speaker 1: All right, a couple of newsworthy items
that I want to touch on the Trump records that
have been sent to the Riot Committee, the Jan.
six Riot Investigative Committee of the House of
Representatives, some of those records were torn
up and taped back together, and this is an M.O.
that we're already familiar with with the Trump
Organization and administration. The Washington
Post reporting some records sent to the Jan.
six committee were torn up, taped back together,
mirroring a Trump habit when the National
Archives and Records Administration handed over
a trove of documents to the House Select Committee
investigating the Jan. six insurrection. Some of
the Trump White House records had been ripped up
and then taped back together, according to three
people familiar with the records. Former President
Trump was known inside the White House for his
unusual and politically unlawful habit of tearing
presidential records into shreds and tossing them
on the floor, creating a headache for records
management analysts who meticulously, meticulously
used scotch tape to piece together fragments of
paper that were sometimes as small as confetti.
As Politico reported in 2018, but despite the
Presidential Records Act, which requires the
preservation of memos, letters, notes, emails,
faxes and other written communications related
to a president's official duties, the former
presidents in fragile shredding practices
apparently continued well into the latter stages
of his presidency. The National Archives on Monday
took the unusual step of confirming the habit,
saying in a statement that records turned over
from the Trump White House quote included
paper records that have been had been torn up
by former President Trump. The statement comes in
response to a question from The Washington Post
about whether some January six related records
had been ripped up and taped back together.
This is about 700 pages of documents transmitted
to the Jan. six committee last months. Now this,
you might remember that not only ripping up
documents is something Donald Trump would
frequently do. There are claims that Trump ate
documents. This is crazy, but we reported on it
back in 2018, and it's all part of the same thing.
Newsweek report Trump eight sensitive documents.
After Cohen meeting former White House aide
claims former White House aide Omarosa Manigault
Newman has said she walked in on President Donald
Trump eating paper after a meeting with lawyer
Michael. You know, this is so insane and what
she believed was an effort to destroy sensitive
information. This was from her book Unhinged,
an insider account of the Trump White House.
Neuman makes a series of disturbing and amusing
allegations about the president's conduct, Newman
recalls. I saw him put a note in his mouth since
Trump was ever the germophobe. I was shocked.
He appeared to be chewing and swallowing
the paper. It must've been something very,
very sensitive. So listen, whether Trump ate
notes or not. There's no doubt at all. Like,
even if Omeros is lying, there's no doubt
whatsoever that the ripping up of the notes was
a common thing. We reported at the time that there
was like a team of a couple of people that were.
Their job was to pick up confetti sized pieces
of paper and tape them back together to remain
in compliance with presidential records and the
like. And of course, this is not the behavior of
an innocent person. And when it comes to records
about what happened on in the lead up to in the
immediate aftermath of the Jan. six Trump riots,
why would he be ripping those up and of course,
innocent until proven guilty? All of that stuff.
But this show is not a court of law, it's a court
of opinion. My opinion, and it is not, in my
opinion, the behavior of an innocent person
last thought on this. I don't have to remind
you that just about every promise that was made
by Donald Trump leading up to his administration
was a lie, or it didn't come true. One of those
claims was We will be the most transparent
administration ever. Remember that Trump had
one press secretary who held zero or one briefings
in her entire tenure. It was a relatively short
tenure, I admit. And also remember that
Trump ran on Hillary can't be trusted
and is not transparent. Hillary's hiding emails.
Hillary deleted email. Hillary used private email.
Hillary can't be trusted with sensitive
information. Hillary can't be trusted with
classified information. And it all happened during
the Trump administration. Trump spilling secrets
that were received from Ally Israel to a Russian
spy recruiter in the Oval Office. Remember that
one? Ivanka Jared, the whole team using private
email throughout their work for Donald Trump
in the administration and on and on and on? So
there's five or six stories here. And shockingly,
the one of Trump eating notes is not
even the craziest or more dangerous one.